outside the home in killamash where he'd
murdered his partner and three children
Damien Bendel is about to tell police
what he's done sorry I don't know what's
going to happen to your army well I know
we just go to prison obviously again wow
you've done something to anyone else
yeah well you don't know there's four
people inside officers found the bodies
of Terry Harris bendel's pregnant
partner her two children 13 year old
John Paul Bennett and 11 year old Lacey
and Lacey's friend Connie gent who'd
been staying for a sleepover Damien it's
zero seven forty seven hours immersing
your suspicion of murder
the children had spent the day selling
sweets to raise money for cancer
research it was as they were getting
ready for bed that Bendel went round the
house attacking them with a claw hammer
then as Lacey Lay Dying he raped her in
the early hours of the following morning
Bendel left the home where his victims
lay Dead with the Xbox that belonged to
the boy he'd murdered he took a taxi to
Sheffield where he exchanged it for
drugs he returned to the house and
appeared calm as he went to a nearby
shop to buy tobacco
he was described in court as truly evil
a drug addict with a long history of
violence
the level of force and violence was
carried out when these attacks was
carried out with one intention and that
was taken that was to take the lives of
those within the premises
they had all by the nature of their
relationship come to trust Bendel and he
took the opportunity to shatter that
trust
these horrendous attacks and the force
in the weapon used would have left
person to tie the premises very quickly
incapacitated in statements read to the
court John Paul and Lacey's father said
I will not see them grow up I will not
have the opportunity to be a Granddad I
am angry their life their future has
been taken away from them I am lost
without them and I need them Connie's
father said I feel like part of my
identity has been taken and feel like I
do not know who I am or what my purpose
in life is anymore my heart is totally
broken and shattered into pieces
the police described Bendel as a monster
sentencing Bendel to a whole life prison
term the judge told him the murders were
brutal vicious and cruel and had caused
utter Devastation for his victims
families
it was an inexplicable apparently
motivless attack on four vulnerable and
defenseless victims Becky Johnson Sky
News at Derby Crown Court